welcome everyone and thank you for
coming
so I'm rohini Pandey I'm a professor of
economics and the director of the
economic growth Center I also together
with Dr Charity Troya Moon direct the
inclusion economics at Yale University
inclusion economics is a policy engaged
research initiative which seeks to
promote inclusive institutions economies
and societies so in that context we're
particularly delighted to have barkada
join us today who has really on the side
of Journalism always sought to provide
news and information that will help
India and I think more broadly South
Asia move towards being more inclusive
before I introduce Barca let me start by
saying that we couldn't have done it
without our co-host the south Asia
studies Council and the pointer
Fellowship in journalism many thanks to
kasturi and Amar at sasc and Bliss and
the pointer team for their help planning
this also a big thank you to Zara Chris
and Jenna who helped planned this event
so let me now briefly introduce barkha I
think she probably needs very little
introduction to the people in the room
she's one of India's best known
journalists who has reported for the
last 25 years from war zones and
conflict areas across the world she is
also the founding editor of Mojo's story
a multimedia digital platform and a
columnist for the Washington Post
she's she's received numerous Awards but
among them are the Padma Shri and the
global leader for tomorrow from the
world economic forum
to write her most recent book to Helen
Back humans of kovit barkha made
multiple path-breaking Journeys across
India conducting ground reporters during
the pandemic
and on tonight's event she's going to
tell us about this
I should also highlight that today's
event actually is a flipped version of a
policy dialogue we had in Delhi in July
where researchers talked about their
findings about the pandemic and and then
burkha was part of a discussion on it
So today we're going to continue the
conversation in a flipped version with
barkha telling us about her journey
through covet and her Reflections on
through through media in India today and
then after that charity will provide
some research insights which complement
barkha's discussion please join me in
welcoming barkhadata
thank you very much you can all hear me
okay
um thank you for coming thank you also
to all of you who uh may be part of this
conversation but are online uh I hope to
have it be an interactive conversation
so looking for lots of questions and
comments from the floor as well as
questions coming in from our audience um
online
okay
um
what I want to say before I start
talking about my journey across India is
that reporting um on covet really helped
me understand many things that I did not
understand before I embarked on this
journey it helped me understand my
country it helped me understand how
power is both wielded and organized
structurally it helped me understand my
role as a journalist and in fact in
particular made me re-examine what the
place is of a media of media Independent
Media
not just in crisis but even at other
times so when I wrote this book to Helen
Back the humans of covet above
everything else uh for me
you know for all of us who live through
the pandemic we kept hearing
things described in terms of numbers
right numbers are important numbers help
us actually uh get a very very empirical
sense of what's going on but we would
hear all the time dashboards that would
tell us caseload that would tell us
hospitalizations mortalities and then
later vaccine numbers and how many
vaccines had been achieved and how many
booster Doses and so on but who were the
people behind these numbers who are the
people who populated the numbers what
were their stories what were their names
did we even know their names and talking
about numbers would all of them even be
counted
I think that is uh that was at the heart
of my uh sort of Journey Across India
and what I'm going to do is to give you
a sense of um
what this uh in a way taught me what I
had to unlearn
um as some of you might know I spent 20
plus years in television uh before I
moved to the digital media some of you
were at lunch today and we were talking
about the incredible shifts in India
which mirrors the shifts globally which
is just to take you through some of that
uh that data there are 650 million
active internet users in India seventy
percent of Indian servants say they get
their news content today uh via the
Internet uh the top two sources of news
are YouTube and WhatsApp and there are
serious questions today over broken
Revenue models in television newsrooms
as well as ownership by Big Business
houses that raise questions over how
free they really are able to be in their
storytelling so for a combination of
reasons shifting technology uh wanting
to be my own boss disillusionment with
talk TV shops uh in which was what the
state of broadcast media was I shift to
little forming my own digital platform
and as I had registered Mojo story and
Mojo means magic I set out to look for
uh the magic of Journalism which I felt
I had forgotten and I wanted to
ReDiscover uh two months or three months
later the pandemic hit so my platform
and my life literally for the last three
years has been consumed by the telling
of this story
so
okay yeah so let me start with um
some images that I think really captured
in a way the Unique Reality of how covet
unfolded in India unique because every
country negotiated covet in its own ways
in every country uh kovid exposed fault
lines that were unique to that country
and in India we had in the first wave
something unfold that we hadn't seen
actually since the partition of India
which was the mass Exodus and the mass
movement of millions of India's poorest
citizens or daily wage workers now why
did this happen it happened simply
because like every other country in the
world India decided to lock down but
when we locked down we also closed
public transport in the first wave so in
the first wave you had no buses no
trains no airports you only had trucks
to some degree plying essential supplies
oil grains and so on and that was pretty
much it
and what happened was that
um though the government issued orders
saying that workers the poor workers who
who live on substance wages must be paid
nobody was paid because economic
activity had come to a grinding halt so
these were men and women who if you know
for those of us those of you who might
be familiar with Indian cities think of
construction sites where a house is
coming up or a factory is coming up they
would live on the site and be given
temporary like a shack to stay in while
the house was coming up or they would
work as help in the fields so they
really had no homes where they had
migrated to they would just live in
these temporary sort of shelters they
would get daily wages and suddenly they
had no source of income secondly there
was an underestimation of the fact that
like you and me uh and I think it's easy
to forget this three years later but the
first wave of covet felt like the end of
the world you didn't know what was going
to happen next um we ran flights to
bring some of you back home to India the
one they Bharat missions but no
transport was actually open for the
poorest workers so they decided men
women and children to start walking home
and these were some of the images that I
chronicled as I followed them
um across India and what I really found
was that women in particular had packed
their universes uh their entire universe
into a little what did Hindi is called a
borea sack
um and and they were just they didn't
know whether they were going to come
back they didn't know if they were ever
going to come back they didn't know if
they were going to make it to their
destinations but their entire universe
packed into a little sack on their head
sometimes their infants carried on their
shoulders often with no food a packet of
biscuits if they were lucky a small
bottle of water if they were lucky this
is how they walked and they walked as I
said hundreds of kilometers often
without shoes
in the scorching heat it was still
extremely hot in North India as they
walked home to shock
um
my erstwhile Medium television and I am
a first generation TV journalist I'm a
child of Television I became a
journalist when the airwaves were
privatized in India we only started
having private news in India in 1995. so
it's not that I sort of was born hating
television I was I was you know
literally groomed by the medium shaped
by the medium but to my absolute shock
there was hardly any TV presence with
boots on the ground television had
decided to basically look away from
these walking workers and concentrate on
Expert driven talk TV which had its
place but was really not capturing the
scale of what was unfolding on sort of
the shiny expressways which at other
moments were actually an illustration of
how much India's infrastructure story
had improved and so on and so the story
of these daily wage workers was told by
independent digital platforms Like Mine
by
Regional reporters in the language press
by Hindi newspapers and by what in my
industry are called stringers which are
really not professional journalists but
let's say you live in a village and you
have a smartphone you might decide to
take a bunch of pictures of what you see
and then you'll contribute that to let's
say a big Network headquartered
somewhere in the city television
effectively just didn't get it out it
didn't get out of the Metros and it sat
in the studios in the meantime we had
this this sort of Crisis unfold and in
some cases
and this is how I started discovering uh
the kind of structural inequalities that
at least my work I had been a war
correspondent and then a political
journalist so I done very little of this
work and I had never really looked at
the issues of structural inequalities
through a mainstream media lens and and
that is what I started doing here now
where I'm sitting right now is actually
the premises of a major Factory in
India's capital Delhi and this was one
of the more extraordinary things I
encountered because the owners of this
Factory as these workers left left the
cities to go back to their homes in The
Villages they decided that they must
stop the workers from doing this right
and what they did was they locked up the
workers uh Behind These Gates these were
the locked Gates as we found them and we
somehow managed to force our way in and
when we went in this is uh we actually
found a board and the board actually
listed the tours in the day that these
workers were allowed to come out for a
cup of tea and a bathroom break I mean
it was literally like locking up chattel
like it was it was just horrendous and
they were completely tone deaf about it
they actually thought that they were
looking after the workers uh by doing
this and when we walked in we found all
of these desolate desperate people and
they were like get us out of here
somehow and when we started filming them
you know we had guards come in
confiscate our tapes try to lock Us in
of course we made a whole lot of noise I
started tweeting the chief minister we
managed to get out of there but in some
ways this was the beginning of my
understanding that till then there was a
media cliche uh that kovid was the great
equalizer but in fact covet was the
exact opposite of the great equalizer
every structural inequity of Indian
society and I'm sure this was true
globally but I can only speak to India
because that's what I reported on uh
whether it was class whether it was cast
whether it was gender
um it was it was exacerbated it was
deepened it was you know that fault line
was just wrenched open and and and you
couldn't you could look away and in fact
I remember meeting in Bombay a woman who
used to live in the slums and she used
to work as a domestic help in the
high-rise skyscrapers all around her and
she said to me she said what kind of
justice is this I'll say it in Hindi and
then I'll translate it uh she said
what kind of justice is this that the
virus came into India traveling on an
airplane and it's the poor person who's
walking on the roads yeah so I think
that's what it was it was it was a while
it impacted everybody the way you
experienced the pandemic very much
depended on uh
what class you were in what gender you
were what cast you were and yes
sometimes what religion you were because
that TV channels not just did not put
people on the ground uh some of them
decided that this was the moment to
actually start communalizing the covet
conversation
the reason this happened is one of the
earliest mass congregations that took
place that was a super spreader event
there's no doubt about it was by an
orthodox Muslim sect called the tabliki
jamaat and this was just at the cusp of
you know the restrictions that were then
subsequently placed on all mass
congregations except of course election
rallies that's that's a different debate
um and and and
this undoubtedly was a congregation that
should not have taken place but once it
did
we actually had channels using hashtags
like Corona Jihad uh this was on a major
television channel the times group and
there was another Network the India
Today Network which uh represented the
kovid dashboard graphically in this in
skull caps so they had Silhouettes
called caps and they put their data of
Harmony what the the count of covet
cases that they was in a skull cap and
you can get the reference um of that so
one every inequity was deepened wrenched
open therefore you know for you to see
unless you were wanting to look away two
um you actually
had big media not just look away but
further sort of add to the toxicity uh
around this conversation so there was
either an invisibilization of what was
happening to the poor and in the second
we have a complete invisibilization of
rural India or there was a kind of
bigoted lens through which the story was
being told
in the meantime something very odd you
know in India they say that everything
you say in its opposite is true and
we're a very very paradoxical country
and even on covet by the way you know
one of the big mistakes that India made
was to order vaccines very late but when
we finally got to it because we have a
history of mass immunization programs
it's one of our big Public Health
successes we actually had boats and
drones and people walking through
jungles deliver vaccines and you know we
became the second country in the world
to cross the two billion Mark after
China in July uh of of of the previous
year so what I'm saying is that
everything you say about India and its
opposite is often true there has to be a
granularity in how we understand my
country and the same thing happened with
the police in this lockdown the police
was First Responders they were among the
First Responders so they were vulnerable
they were Brave I met a policeman whose
hand was cut off for trying to sort of
enforce the lockdown uh but on the other
hand the police was also weaponized
sometimes against the poorest citizens
so what was happening was that these
people would try and leave the daily
wage workers and they would be pushed
back from barricades by the police some
of them would fold their hands and plead
some of them would bribe their way some
of them would just revolt and say okay
arrest me if you want to but I'm just
breaking this barricade but a lot of
people would just keep walking to the
city barricade and we turned back from
it and then have to walk
you know dozens of sort of Miles again
to reach that barricade to be turned
back again and again and this was SEMA
who was married to a scrap seller you
know he used to just buy what in India
is called kabadi like your waste uh the
newspapers that you finish reading at
the end of the day tin cans that you're
you know basically garbage and the and
and repurpose it right so he was a scrap
seller she was married uh to him and
they were trying to get back to their
Village and she just collapsed in tears
literally in my arms uh making me step
back from my old-fashioned Notions of
what is objectivity at this time you
know I had gone to Jay school and I'd
been taught that a journalist must have
emotional distance from the story that
you're telling but in a situation like
this how is that emotional distance
possible is it even uh desirable
then we come to the story of of Poonam
now one of the things that happened and
I'm sure
rohini and Charities data may have done
some work on this is what are the assets
that a poor person has at this time
right so for most of India's poorest
people the one asset that they owned was
a phone
so when people didn't know what to do
and how to make ends well sort of make
ends meet they sold the only thing they
had which was a phone
so when I was telling uh the story of
these migrant workers and I could
realize that there was a class gap
between my audience and the story and
the class of the people I was telling so
now I had an audience that was
baking banana bread on Instagram
talking about going to the Maldives
talking about the covet blue of the sky
that had suddenly been liberated from
delhi's air pollution and I had to make
this class of people
care about the poorest worker at a time
when let's face it they were also
frightened right so how were you going
to bridge this cast divide you had to
come back to compelling storytelling so
I could have said you know millions of
Migrant workers are impacted and that
would be true but instead I chose to
tell the story of a man called Mukesh
mandal Mukesh Mantra was a house painter
that's his photograph that his wife
Poonam is holding up and he used to do
the odd job painting homes as they came
up on construction sites and like
everybody else when the lockdown
happened his work came to a grinding
Halt and suddenly there was no food to
feed his children so he sold his phone
and he sold his phone for 2000 rupees
with those two thousand rupees he bought
a table fan for 500 rupees because it
was really really hot uh still in in
those months of Delhi and then or rather
outskirts of Delhi he lived in haryana
and then
he bought some wheat he bought some
lentils he bought some grains and he
took it to his wife who was relieved
thinking that at least this week
we won't go hungry my children won't go
hungry but the next day Mukesh felt a
deep anxiety and he felt that he had
nothing else left to say he could not
see any visible Improvement in the
future he didn't know what to do so he
went to his wife Poonam and he asked to
borrow her uh what we call a dupatta the
scarf and he took this he took the
dupatta he tied it to the bamboo pole of
their one room tournament and he took
his own life
and
in my opinion this was a starvation
death
um it was the fear of hunger that led
him to to die he had no visible source
of income and in the lockdown even the
distribution of free Russians which were
announced by all governments was
extremely difficult because the lockdown
was became like a police enforced curfew
uh as opposed to a people-led protective
measure right so but the District
administration that I went to meet
subsequently said that he was mentally
unstable the family was made to put they
were illiterate and they were made to
put their thumb imprint on a set of
papers to say that he they didn't even
understand what they were signing and
they were and then the police could
quote that piece of paper and say uh
that he was mentally unstable
meanwhile the workers kept walking you
would see images like this that they
would with folded hands stop a truck
driver say please let us get on and the
truck driver in this case said no the
police will come after me I can't give
you a ride not even for a few kilometers
and this went on for almost 60 days into
the pandemic you had workers walking
till this case reached the Supreme Court
and you know through forests through
night time
um this became a parallel crisis to the
medical crisis where already you had
beds running short and you didn't have
enough doctors and I remember one doctor
telling me I feel like I've been sent to
fight a nuclear war with a Lati with a
stick
one such truck looked like this at the
back uh initially the cops wouldn't let
me see what was happening so I just had
to fight with them and insist that I I
could get it look in and I saw like you
know it it it looked like every Human
Trafficking movie that I'd seen it was
just like just these people like lumped
together desperate to get out and I
asked one of them that you know aren't
you scared of getting covered like that
was the basic question right I'm just
scared of getting covered and he said
well the poverty will kill me before the
virus will
and so he left
one of the things that occurred to me
was
when I saw these little sort of sacks
being carried by women mostly on their
head as the men carry the children
what do you carry when you leave
when you leave and you don't know if
you'll make it to your destination and
you don't know whether you'll come back
this was also a question that partition
researchers have now looked at what did
people carry you know I come from a kind
of refugee family my parents my father's
side of the family lived in undivided
when India was undivided on the Pakistan
side in Seattle court and I grew up
hearing these stories about you know our
family had this and our family had this
and there was a piano in the house and
there was this and there was this and
then we came with nothing now of course
many people came with nothing but even
those who came with nothing and came as
literally poor people with you know they
went from being wealthy to being poor
overnight everybody carried something
one thing one thing that meant something
to them and so as I saw these people
walk I wanted to know what did they
carry and the answer was so
moving and humbling for me and this was
their answer They carried in a plastic
bucket so many of them that I met their
Workman stones
uh and and of course they carried a
couple of clothes and maybe a packet of
biscuits and a blanket for their child
but They Carried their what in Hindi is
called their ozar their tools and they
said maybe we'll get work on the way
maybe maybe something maybe there'll be
somebody who'll give us work
so even through This calamity even
through this crisis these were people
who were desperate they were not begging
they were not saying give us a door they
were just like we want to work but there
is no work
and there was no at that point there was
no sort of Social Security net because
they would they were like a displaced
they were at that point an internally
displaced community so the idea that
they could get to a bank account where a
direct cash transfer had taken place or
through this sort of barricaded police
um monitoring of of movement they would
even be able to access the social
welfare program was an unrealistic uh
sort of idea and so They Carried their
tools this was somewhere in in Telangana
in the South and then there was this
nine-year-old child and I playfully
asked him I said oh do you know what
Corona virus is uh by this time uh I
some public transport had started with
the intervention of the Supreme Court
and he was standing in light to take a
bus back with his father to his to his
village and he said of course I know
what it means and I said what does it
mean and he said it means I don't get
food to eat
and that was a nine-year-old child's
understanding so you know when we look
at coveted the pandemic as a as a
medical story as a story of science as a
story of doctors and drugs it is all of
those things but for so many countries
it is also a story of power and access
to resources and inequity but it's also
a story of Hope and compassion and
kindness as I subsequently discovered in
my in my story
um in my journey
one of the odd things that happened in
India was that there was either
too much centralization or too little
centralization so sometimes you just had
entire districts and it was left to the
district magistrate the local
bureaucrats in the area to take a
decision and at other times like with
the use of police you know you had too
much state or too little state the the
overarching presence of the police was
the state when you didn't need it and
outside the hospitals when people would
go from hospital to hospital and there
was not one person either at the state
level or at the central level to tell
them where to go next and I witnessed
people dying on the road at the closed
doors of of Hospital uh Gates there was
no state so you know when you needed the
state it will it went missing when you
didn't want the state there was too much
of it
old people uh suffered in an ex you know
I'm sure for those of you who were here
during the pandemic when any of you here
during the pandemic with families back
home
with with families back home okay so you
know what you would have been going
through thinking about your parents or
your grandparents right
um
it's really strange but of all the
stories I did this one just cut across
classes and and and genres of viewers
because I think it spoke either to
everybody's concern about their parents
or it spoke to everybody's guilt about
their parents or it spoke to everybody's
fear about drawing old
um and this was Leela vati who was 70
years old and she was a widow she had
come to meet her son in Bombay and then
when the lockdown hit the sun decided
that he could not look after his aging
mother he didn't have any source of
income and he was an alcoholic so he
threw her out and I I because I was now
following the workers and by now trains
it started running I met her sitting
outside a railway station in Bombay and
you know uh she'd had no food no money
and I said where are you going she said
I don't know can you put me on a train
and I said but even if I put you on a
train where should I send you and she
said none of my children will have me
but can you send me to Delhi because
that's the city I know best because I I
was you know I used to live there when
my husband was alive so I said but okay
I'll send you to Delhi but what do you
do and she said I'll beg
and I I didn't know what to do uh you
know all I could do was to tell her
story and hope that somebody would take
notice and that is what happened uh
which is that when we released this
story the railways then took her into
the waiting room they put her on a train
and a politician in Delhi actually took
her in as a temporary measure
um till her daughter agreed to take her
back but the story of lilavati I mean I
I have never seen like till this date
three years later somebody finds a story
on Mojo story they write to me saying
can we financially help her and it it
spoke to all of our I think Collective
vulnerability this was Jyoti uh Jyoti
got the attention of Ivanka Trump uh for
all the wrong reasons who decided to
treat her trauma as a sporting
achievement instead of the trauma that
it was she was a 15 year old who cycled
with her father at the back of the cycle
1200 kilometers from Delhi to Bihar the
reason that the father couldn't uh ride
the cycle is because he just had a knee
surgery so he couldn't peddle a cycle
was luxury most other people were
walking and those shoes fitted by the
world as this sort of champion and she
was given many free Cycles like you know
what was she going to do with those
Cycles uh
she kept saying and I met her twice and
she kept saying you know all I want to
do is study and that is that is
literally my only dream and I cried
every night we would stay at the gas
stations the petrol pumps on the highway
I was a young girl that was a family
later one of the few Happy Endings of
this story she she became such a global
star uh that her house became the first
Brick House in her Village because
people did offer to financially uh
support her there's now a movie being
made on her but again I will say that
there was a kind of Romancing of this
story a romanticization of the story
this 50 no 15 year old girl should have
to cycle back home uh through a pandemic
with her father at the back of the cycle
through a lockdown uh she should never
have had to do that and there was a
great Romanticism uh I met her in a
village in Bihar and she said I've got
15 Cycles would like to try one so we
went to recycle right she took me to her
school and she said all I want to do is
study one of the other things that we
don't talk about and I really felt
strongly about this during the pandemic
is what happened to other people who
were ill they would you know other
illnesses it did not stop uh and and so
whether it was kidney disease whether it
was cancer whether it was little
children falling ill needing a heart
surgery we saw this happening we saw
poor people in particular come to the
sort of the gates of Public Health
hospitals because that's all they could
afford those hospitals were taken over
and become totally covered hospitals and
so suddenly you had
you know people burying their children
uh these were five girls whose father
died from tuberculosis he was a he was a
tea vendor this was a cancer patient I
met outside one of the hospitals and he
was just told by the guard now you go to
the next hospital he's like what's the
next hospital and he didn't no one could
tell him where to go so he was just this
lonely man I just met outside one of the
public health hospitals in Delhi and he
was just walking that's the those are
the five girls who lost their father to
tuberculosis now this story I was
talking about the Paradox of the police
being both uh vulnerable Brave
frontliners and also weaponized against
the most vulnerable citizens
this was Manoj she used to ride a
rickshaw an electronic Rickshaw and
because there was no food he decided
that he wanted to go and buy some
vegetables from the wholesale market so
he wandered outside of the permissible
area that was allowed in the lockdown
and the police got hold of him they beat
him and they his arm was fractured they
beat him and they deposited him outside
a hospital which wouldn't take him in
and
because truth is so much more dramatic
Than Fiction this image to me was the
most ironic image because I found him
leaning against this police barricade
beaten by the police left by the police
outside this Hospital which wouldn't
take him in
and what did he do he just went out to
buy vegetables these were workers who
died in a road accident remember they
were taking lifts where they could and
their bodies were put in shoved into
plastic packets and sent back home on
Ice Labs the only surviving worker of
this accident said that we are being
treated worse than insects
those are scenes from that accident side
and this
um by the time trains were opening it
started with freight trains good trains
that were carrying essential supplies
tribal workers uh decided they came from
a very very remote Village in the
heartland of India in madhya Pradesh and
according to me you know sometimes a
single image tells you the whole story
of a pandemic and the image I'm going to
show you next to me is I think probably
the most stunning image I have seen out
of the pandemic
these were men who they were all men
they were uh us they were walking home
hundreds of kilometers like everybody
else and they decided to sleep on the
rail tracks for two reasons they thought
there are no passenger trains because
there were no passenger trains and two
they thought they could hide from the
police who might send them back that as
they lay there at four in the morning a
good strain that was carrying supplies
came and ran over them all 18 of them
died and this is all that remained of
them a little packet of Roti a bread
that they packed it was like I said food
was scarce there was even if you had
money there was no shops no dhabas no
roadside
sort of you know
properties that were open and this this
was what remained with them and I went
to their Village it was literally on my
100th day on the road I went to the
village and I
it was the toughest place to get to I
say this is someone who has covered war
and riots and and Calamity that it was
such a remote Village that it you it
took me 18 hours by Road and then
another few hours on foot
to get to where they came from and
nobody had thought who were these people
who died on the rail tracks what was the
name of their Village what you know what
were their names
and I met their families and like this
we moved into the second wave and in the
second way we learned a lot from the
first wave we did not shut public
transport you know we learned
that hospitals should not be converted
into coveted only hospitals because
there are people dying from other
ailments that also need medical
intervention but now we this was a
pregnant a new a new mother Rebecca
pardon who just gave birth to our one
day old baby and she had coveted she had
no hospital to go to now this became the
crisis right now you couldn't get up
there in hospital
you just couldn't get a bed in hospital
and if you could get a bed in hospital
you couldn't get oxygen
and I met people who were made to sign
what I have called modern day death
wardens because they were just made to
sign waivers saying and it is in the
hospital's fault frankly uh because they
didn't have the oxygen they were made to
sign Warren saying that if your loved
one dies from a shortage of oxygen you
will not Sue the hospital
right uh I saw something I never thought
I would see in my life gurdwaras which
are Sikh places of worship normally have
a what's called a Langer which is a free
meal for the very poor right halwa Dal I
mean some of you would be familiar with
the language in India started oxygen
lungers now
this is also about the hope and the
compassion that one saw where
governments were missing people stepped
in
uh social media for one for once became
a mechanism for good people would say do
you know someone
who can supply oxygen do you know
someone who can give me some Supply and
gurdwara's started what was called
oxygen lungers and you would see scenes
like this where there would be giant
oxygen cylinders placed on the road
somebody could drive in or come on a
rickshaw poor Rich it didn't matter you
were allowed to have access to a single
oxygen cylinder for half an hour then
you had to move on and and make room for
the next person it was like the
McDonald's of oxygen it was like a
drive-through and it feels almost like
weird now to for me to say it like this
but this is what it was it was a drive
through oxygen lunger in the meantime
people started taking cardboard strips I
actually met a family that slept on
cardboard strips on the floor of this
was a Bombay Hospital these were the
images from our cremation grounds our
our graveyards our hospitals just
absolute devastation and now we come to
this image which became a major major
fault line in India's internal
discussions
how many people have died from covet we
started this conversation by saying that
numbers didn't tell the full story you
needed to know the people behind the
numbers the unfortunate Dimension to
this is we don't even know the numbers
right the epidemiologists uh
all vary in their estimation the World
Health Organization says 10 times more
people have died in India than the
official count
the middle of all of this I remember
this day well it was one day before my
father died my father died from covet
and it was very strange for me we were
in the second wave by now this had been
my whole life and I literally became the
story I had been reporting obviously
albeit with all the caveats that I came
from privilege when my father couldn't
get a hospital bed I was able to call a
doctor I was able to say please get him
a hospital bed the doctor agreed but the
hospital was an hour away
and
uh there was no ambulance available at
that time and I made a mistake that
continues to haunt me that we my sister
and I got what was called a private
agency and they said we you know it's a
private ambulance but when the so-called
ambulance arrived
it was a broken down van like a really
old ramshackled van it had a hard bench
at the back it had a kind of rusty giant
oxygen cylinder lying on the floor and
it had he didn't even have a mask there
was only a driver there were no
paramedics and I had to make a split
second decision do I sell this guy away
do I just wait for the hospital you know
ambulance and I made the decision to
jump on the front seat and go with my
father all the while driving through a
snail of traffic that had again been
created by police barricades who were
trying to enforce a lockdown
anyway there was a whole mile long of
other daughters possibly in ambulances
with their fathers and here we go to
this hospital and by the time we reach
the hospital
uh
we my father was supposed to be admitted
to a general room and the the doctors on
emergency Duty they checked his oxygen
and they found that the cylinder hadn't
worked as it was meant to so his oxygen
levels had plummeted and he had to be
admitted to an Ico there was no Ico bed
and literally I spent a year and a half
telling this story about other people
people outside hospitals people not able
to get a bed people desperate I now
became that desperate person please I
need an Ico bed we got the Ico bed but
it was the last time that I saw him
alive
and five days later when he died we had
to cremate him near
um the hospital
because the hospital was technically in
another state and it would have needed
police permission to bring him back home
so we couldn't bring him back home
and at The Cremation ground there was no
space to commit so we actually had to
call the police to say that can you
please help us cremate our father and
that evening I tested positive for covet
so it was very surreal but I remember
this image because it was the evening
before my father I took my father to
hospital and it was a cremation ground
where this was the image and you knew
and and the and the caretaker of The
Cremation ground told me that the
official number from the city that week
had been 30 but he had handled 300
bodies in a day
and so it became my kind of mission
after I got better it was also the only
way I knew how to deal with loss and
grief that I was going to change the
story of the uncounted covet deaths
because I felt that I mean we are
criticized the media ourselves saying
people can't just be numbers and now we
were saying they weren't even numbers
but when we had these images and some of
us did we were called vultures uh by by
trolls who said that we were feasting
off the dead and we were sort of you
know why were we showing these images
and look at the American Press because
you know it never does a story on
masquerades this is not true I've
personally pulled out several stories
from the front pages of the post of the
New York Times that had actually done
similar stories on uncounted covert
deaths here in the United States of
America so it's not that this did not
happen here
um but then this this was another
cremation ground where literally bodies
were lying on the floor like this
because there was just no place uh to to
to to to actually cremate them this is
Drone footage of the banks of the Ganga
so before I show you the next few
visuals I just want you to understand
what was happening remember we spoke in
the beginning of invisibilization by the
media of a number of things that were
Happening by the time the second wave
happened if in the first wave the daily
wage workers had been invisibilized by
the second wave rural India did not
figure in covet reporting it just didn't
figure in covet reporting now what was
happening in The Villages of India is
that people were not testing either they
were not testing because they were
stigma or they were not testing because
there was no access to testing or if
they were testing they didn't know what
to do next because they were not they
were you know hospitals weren't close by
enough to access
so what started happening is that if you
would go to Villages you would find that
the panchayat would tell you the local
sort of Village governance module would
tell you that in these last two months
we have seen a surge in the number of
people dying from fever and
cold and breathlessness which would of
course symptoms of of this respiratory
disorder that we understood covet to be
but had they been tested no and because
they hadn't been tested they would never
be counted among the dead and because
rural India was completely invisibilized
nobody was documenting these so you were
not counted if you died at home
you were not counted if you did not get
an RT PCR test I have met people who
spent their days
you know in an ambulance trying to get
tested and couldn't get tested and then
died in the ambulance that would not be
counted as a covert death and you would
not count it as dead if you died from a
shortage of oxygen which scores of
people did as oxygen just ran out in the
icos
and you would if your death certificate
did not list covet as the cause of death
and there were states where the local
Administration was instructed that you
don't get into the cause of death let
the hospital decide the hospital would
say oh of oxygen than shot but I'm not
going to give that as a cause of death
cause of death was cardiac disorder
right so through the cracks of official
term
um the way the system was set up the
fact that many people couldn't get a
death certificate the fact that the
cause of death became something that the
administration and private hospitals
started farming off to one another and
again remember if you think of Mukesh
mandal who had sold his phone now you
had objectively poor people who sold
again everything they owned maybe a
piece of jewelry maybe a piece of land
in the belief that A Private Hospital
would save lives they thought okay
public Hospital the public health system
is totally overridden maybe the public
the private hospitals will and then in
so many of these private hospitals the
oxygen rant shot in the meantime there
were some family that was so poor that
they did not even have wood to burn the
Dead so for a combination of these
reasons we started seeing this very
tragic phenomena in North India and
parts of North India where bodies were
thrown into rivers or left on the
Riverbanks in the dead of night but just
what is called the ram Nami cloth which
is a sacred cloth for for uh for Hindus
and this is the kind of scene that you
would see
um you know as you travel down the banks
off of the river but this became a
really really politicized conversation
and by 2021 I was I started to feel a
kind of Fury at everything I was seeing
and you know I'm a political junkie I
live for elections I live to cover
elections and then but at that time it
seemed to me to be so
I don't know Immortal and egregious that
elections were being held while this is
what was I was Finding on the banks that
elections were being held while schools
were closed right that uh government
employees who were teachers in
government schools were forcibly sent on
Election Duty for local elections and
more than a thousand of them died from
covid these were all lower income
families who were employed a pregnant
woman was among them so I I was for the
first time in my democracy that I'm
otherwise proud of I was really offended
by the fact that these elections were
being held and I I decided to not cover
the elections like I maybe it made a
difference to nobody but I at my level
boycotted and I don't really believe in
boycotts but I'm not going to cover
these elections these elections should
be held so I so there was a gain in this
media disconnect because by now the
media had just turned away from all of
this and was back on the elections and
the elections were the headlines these
were not the headlines right and this is
what was happening on the banks of our
River many of these places were not
reachable by a road you had to get onto
a motorcycle you had to walk uh you have
to take a boat
uh you know down the Ganga
and
finally uh we said in the beginning that
every existing inequity was exacerbated
by covid among the things I discovered
was what happened to cast groups whose
traditional occupation was to wash the
bodies of the Dead
and these cast groups existed even
within Muslims so this was Hyderabad
where I met a man who said I'm a body
washer that was his professional
occupation he actually had an ID card
that said this and nobody was willing to
come near these families and in Varanasi
uh where where Hindus among Hindus
traditionally washed the body and were
washing coveted bodies before they were
taken to the fire
oh
I remember what one of them said and
this happened in front of me I was
walking with him in front of a cremation
ground and there was a shopkeeper and he
said get away from here he said to this
this young man who's washing everybody's
bodies before they were they were late
and he said look at this we are doing
we're doing what families want
but we are still treated like this and
now doubly so because we are washing the
bodies of the covet death
so
I guess in effect you know there were
things of course that were uplifting
they were for the poison that we saw on
television channels I met Community
groups where Hindus and Muslims buried
incremented each other's uh sort of you
know each other's dead
um I met a man called Abdul Mulberry in
Surat in Gujarat where he had one
ambulance and the ambulance said
funerals for lonely humans and his one
purpose in life was to go and according
to your faith he performed the last ride
so in his sort of closet sized
you know uh is causes side office he had
uh he had ganga Jal which is the Sacred
Water of the river ganga but he also had
Namaz mats in the housing societies of
uh of Surat uh I met women who were
Homemakers who said we don't know how to
help but maybe we can cook five more
rotis than we do and every day we'll
cook these rotis we saw people rally
together and behind each other help
perfect strangers and when we finally
got our act together in terms of getting
the vaccines out as I said in the
beginning we did we did well uh we had
very minimal vaccine hesitancy compared
to the kind of politics you see around
it here uh you know once once we learned
from our mistakes we learned but by then
so many people had paid a very very
costly price and I think
I'll just start by saying like I know
it's difficult to remember covert I know
that
people don't want to remember it but
again I'll draw parallel with Partition
where you know Ashish nandi who's one of
India's best sociologists he did this
project called memory and partition and
one of the things he argued was that
whenever something cataclysmic happens
in the life of a people or in the life
of a Nation like the partition of India
the instinct is to put a lid on it and
to bury the memory and the moment you
bury a memory there is a kind of
schizophrenia that that that develops
and has developed as as we see between
India and Pakistan and covet is
something similar I think we are
desperate to forget I can understand
that I live nothing else for two two
years plus
um I I get the whole need to move on but
I think if we don't pause to think okay
what did we teach us about ourselves uh
what did it teaches about our
relationships what did it teaches about
Society about the organization of Power
about
I don't know access to resources what
should policy be going forward uh you
know why why aren't these things that
people vote on the quality of air the
quality of Health Care there's so much
to think about here you know and for me
personally you know I call reporting the
Cargill war in 99 my first master class
in life I was 26 and a half I covered
covert in my 40s and it really literally
was the second master class in life it
made me re-examine every assumption of
what I understood to be the role of a
journalist what I understood to be my
role what I understood to be the
hierarchy of news what I understood
about TV channels about the people of
India and and I and I think those
discussions continue many things are not
many things don't have certitude uh but
as long as one can at least begin asking
the questions now with the benefit of
some distance uh I think that will be
the lesson we need to take away
otherwise you know it may not be covered
it'll be something else tomorrow and and
our fault lines will be wrenched open uh
once again so I'll just stop there thank
you very much
[Applause]
that was all absorbing and also
heart-wrenching and I think I speak for
everyone you know we're sorry for your
loss as well of your father through all
this but thank you for sharing that and
for taking that Journey over those two
years as well I think you did a huge
service
um for all of us to really understand
what what has happened
um I'm going to turn right now and I
hope that this works if I just move
ahead with the slides yes
um to some research insights so I'm
going to try to put some data to some of
the faces that you showed us and I want
to turn to the issue of gender and I
know we don't have a lot of time so I'm
going to ask two questions and then I
think we can open it up for the audience
and the people online as well so we make
sure we can have time with them so um in
July when we were together we talked a
little bit about some of the surveys
that we've conducted through inclusion
economics so that's uh let me come a
little closer things that's uh you know
with rohini here um Jenna Allard who's
in the audience myself Yusuf neggar
Simone Shaner and then Malik jagani here
with other university these so when
covet hit we decided you know what can
we do I think like many people we were
thinking what can we do to help right
and what we knew we could do is we can
collect data and at least try to
document and then share information
about the migrants in particular but
just anyone that we could collect data
on to understand what was happening
through this crisis and we worked with
government partners and they said we
don't really understand what's happening
um so please do help us help us
understand in particular these migrants
that are leaving cities and so the
migrants you know as they were returning
back to their home States they were
intercepted and people would collect
their details and then we use that
information to call these individuals
and ultimately what we did is we went
back to a core group of migrants about
four different times to understand how
well they were doing through the
pandemic so just to kind of show you we
surveyed them over a 15-month period we
reached out to them four different times
and had 1780 individuals that returned
to Bihar and chattisgarh to just
understand what had happened to them and
what came out from this in particular
was a real gender gap in gender
disparities in terms of you know being
able to return to life as usual
particularly for those who had worked
prior to the pandemic so I'm going to
focus in on the group of migrants who
are already working so these were many
women in India don't work of course
outside the home but we're only focusing
focusing on men and women who worked
prior to the pandemic and what I'll show
you is you know we have information
sorry it's going to be hard for you to
see her but at the beginning of the
pandemic you know we're looking at all
women who are working about four and
five we're working in some sort of
unskilled labor and we surveyed them
through what we called recovery phase
one in phase two and then in covid phase
two and what we saw is that these women
ended up going from skilled labor often
into unskilled labor or more commonly
agricultural jobs or just dropping out
of the labor force entirely and that
persisted all the way through the end of
the second phase of covid where half of
the women that we spoke with who had
previously been employed in urban areas
they were no longer employed many of
these women were stuck back at home in
The Villages and and could not actually
return if we compare it to the figure
for men what we see here is about half
of the men were in skilled labor and
then as a pandemic hit again agriculture
absorbed lots of migrants and was able
to help them especially through that
first wave and about by the end and by
the second wave about a third of the men
were unemployed even during this this
downturn but it didn't really compare
well to what was going on for women
um and as I mentioned sorry this is
probably too much information on one
side but essentially women were stuck in
rural areas the ones that were remaining
in rural areas had a much more difficult
time actually finding work in particular
and you know this was 15 months after
the pandemic began and that's what we
see we also see that women you know
failed to recover their earnings even
prior to the pandemic of course they
were earning less money than men on
average but if we look at what happened
to them sorry for the blurriness at the
bottom not sure why that is
um if we look at uh you know their
recovery essentially men were able to
recover you know very close to the level
that they earned prior to the pandemic
but these women again were not able to
do that
and then finally these women too
particularly the ones that were kind of
stuck in rural areas 15 months after the
pandemic began we were reporting that
they were likely to reduce consumption
and more so than kind of other men and
or men and those who had gone into urban
areas as well so all that to say just
wanted to show you some of what we had
gathered and I'd love to hear your
perspective in particular what happened
to women through the pandemic and what
you saw through that gender lens
um
I mean I think that as we say every
inequity was Amplified and that is what
happened to women as well
and what I remember is during the
pandemic
pregnant women
really struggling to get access to any
health care that is my first memory of
covet like you actually had to have
doctors go into slums or do these
virtual calls and you would meet these
pregnant women on the streets you know
when we spoke about the other people who
needed health care so that is my first
memory you know think of all these
pregnant women secondly uh in India at
least I don't know how it was here
pregnant women got vaccine access to
vaccines lost there was the debate just
carried on over whether it was safe not
safe and finally it was like a group of
sort of uh doctors that led the demand
and said that this must must happen but
what happened inside homes is is in fact
very very distressing uh we have we had
a distinct spike in the reported cases
of domestic abuse
we don't even know right now what the
unreported cases may have been like the
government run child helpline was
deluged with calls uh from children and
girls mostly saying that we do not we're
being forced into underage marriage
uh I went to investigate one of these
Trends and I ended up in a village in
Rajasthan where I basically found that
what was happening was that because we
had among the longest physical School
lockdowns in the world
in a vast number of girls were just out
of the classroom if a family had one
internet device then if there was a boy
it was given to the boy and so you had
all of these girls who had nothing to do
and then their families would tell them
that since you're doing nothing you
should go and get married
and one of the saddest things I ever
heard was one of the activists was
working with these girls told me that in
some cases it's the mothers who are
pushing for these girls to go to the
so-called infant husbands Village
because with the man at home if he
turned abusive or violent uh or or or in
some cases forced sex on his partner and
remember these are horns we're talking
about in very enclosed tiny spaces the
mothers didn't think their daughters
were safe at all and they actually
thought that the daughters may be safer
if so some did it because of what are
you doing go get married some did it
because they thought that they were
actually creating distance between their
girls in an abusive house uh of course
like with everything else in India these
girls answered it by forming a football
team it was just an incredible story
they formed a football team and every
time the village Elders would say what
are you doing let's say we play football
and then they actually became state
level football players but not every
village had that kind of sort of happy
ending and let's not pretend that this
happened only to the poor we had I think
if I'm not wrong please you you guys are
the experts at some point I think the
female labor force participation number
hit nine percent at one point in the
pandemic uh and and basically what was
happening was that even in the PLU Class
People Like Us uh with Partners at home
with children at home
you know this work from home today
sounds like a concept which is meant to
make your life easier but if you're a
woman in India and there is no equality
at home there's no degendering of the
workspace of the of the home space about
your pardon of the roles at home of
whose job it is to put the food on the
table and whose job it is to get the
children dressed and whose job it is to
also do your job right that burden fell
inordinately on women and women just
stopped walking women just said we can't
do this so everything from vaccine
access to access to health care for
pregnant women to domestic violence to
underage marriages to having to leave
your work this this was a very very very
gendered experience and the other thing
is that women
at least in our cultural context are so
conditioned to be all sacrificing there
is so much romance around the
sacrificing woman that you don't hear a
lot of these stories till you go out to
seek them the women don't come forth to
complain because they have over Decades
of cultural conditioning internalize
that if there's one Roti in the house my
heart my child and my husband will eat
it first so I haven't even begun to get
into sort of the malnourishment data or
the maternal mortality data that would
have emerged in in these years but
anecdotally this is what I I saw
happening I saw it I saw women leaving
work in educated upper middle classrooms
I literally I mean I know women when I
literally was like don't do it you'll
regret it it'll be tough to get back
because we just can't take the anxiety
of it so at every layer you saw women
experiencing the pandemic in a very very
different way yeah
definitely resonates
um uh okay so I have one last question
for you thank you for that uh and then
we can open it up to the audience and
people online too and that is you know
you referenced I think we're probably
the group of people that if we were in
India we were baking banana bread and
maybe sending some money to someone or
in the U.S making sourdough bread or
whatever it was
um you know and you know you told the
story about this young boy what does
Corona you know mean what is Corona it
was it means that I'm hungry so um you
know kovid's not the last shock we're
all going to face and I think you know
you said you want us to learn from this
so I just practically speaking what can
we do how can we help you know consider
those that are you know completely
invisalized and marginalized in the
day-to-day yeah
I mean to be completely honest I if I
weren't a journalist I would have also
been at home with the same I come from
the same class I come from privilege so
you know I may I may self-identify as
middle class but that is more a cultural
value than an economic
condition uh and and so I don't want to
be I I wasn't meaning to be holier than
thou or being judgy I was just saying
that was the fact of life that upper
middle class Indians were distraught
with anxiety and they were dealing with
it by entertaining themselves with all
kinds of new sort of cooking skills or
whatever and I would have done the same
head I've been sitting at home and not
been among the people
I I basically think we have to ask more
of our political class and our media as
people on this side you have to ask more
of it you see right now what really
scares me is that there is a growing
disconnect between people and politics
and people and media and I think a lot
of people like I think Reuters had this
study where they spoke about this new
genre of people who are news avoiders
basically like like growing number of
people now feel there's no point by
engaging with journalism because my
firstly it's all bad news I don't want
to feel bad or I don't want to be
triggered or what can I do about it
anyway so you know what it's just better
that I don't know it and I have friends
like this dear friends who at the end of
like a bear from hell I'll go back and
say don't you know this happens they'll
be like what and in some ways and
grateful for them because they keep me
real and there's another dimension to my
life it's the other level it's
instructive to me that there is just
such a gap that nobody today actually
feels that what the media shows you is
something that impacts you the media is
just something other people do it's just
some something that journalists do how
does it impact your life right so I
think till we start asking more of our
journalists and more of our governments
everywhere in the world I mean it really
bothers me I as
as a person who lives in Delhi who has
become asthmatic in her 40s that I am
not I live in a city where people don't
vote on the basis of
what the quality of air is that we as
women don't vote on the basis of you
know who might have a policy that is
more sort of Forward Thinking when it
comes to work right and of course people
are many things we're not just women or
citizens of Delhi or just in many
different things and politics elections
are won and lost on a multiple set of
issues but what can we do is to not I
think the biggest thing we can do is to
not disengage I I I just fear that there
is such a disengagement it is so deep
between people and politics and people
and media that I I really believe that
the next Calamity and there will be a
next Calamity I mean would we have
globally learned anything from it you
know I I remember looking at I was
looking at the U.S from Delhi and I was
like how can you not have
anybody like how can there be such
tolerance for anti-vaxxers how
self-indulgent is it that people are
dying in my country because they can't
get access to vaccines in the first
stage when we had the government hadn't
purchased enough and there are vaccines
just going waste in other parts of the
world right but who's engaged who's
making a noise how do you and the second
thing is and I really believe this is a
Storyteller that you have to have
a way to communicate outside of your
Echo chamber there is no purpose in my
saying this to people who already think
like me so then what have we achieved
and if it takes some you know academic
to get onto Tick Tock if it takes me to
learn how to do a 30 second video
instead of
40 minute talk I have to learn how to do
it
we just have to get off our preachy
little high horses and figure out a
language that actually speaks to a
people who are outside of how we think
and I think the collapse of conversation
across differences of opinion in America
in India this is costly to framing
policy because policies for all policy
exists whether which irrespective of
which party you vote and therefore there
has to be some way of finding consensus
on policy
and and with the polarization in media
in politics I really worry about finding
that consensus for policy
I definitely think that's an issue here
right now uh people
if there's researchers and some story
was even just hearing about family
conversations you know you know maybe in
curtail those and be self-censor I think
a lot um you know and also disengage uh
shall we go ahead with some questions
from the audience or sorry I'll let you
kind of lead where we start so does
anyone here have questions if you do go
ahead and raise your hand and we've got
a few uh
audience online as well
thank you first of all for your time for
coming here I follow you
um your channel on YouTube and also on
Facebook
um so talking about holding politicians
accountable I wholeheartedly agree with
you on this so I grew up in Calcutta and
I am very much in touch
with everything that's going on in India
especially in Bengal so I begin my day
with NDTV and CNN and
um
I can you know confirm that it's not the
ideal way to start my day
so last week I called while I was
watching the Indian news
um I called the ABP Network yes yes
um because a politician who I know
um you know had very humble beginnings
and really became uber wealthy in a few
years if it happens and he had an eye
issue that was bothering him and like
all politicians India wasn't good enough
so he flew to Johns Hopkins to get his
eye tested and apparently he's also
going to be back for a follow-up
appointment and I can barely make it to
New York City for my follow-up
appointments
um I asked the person who took the call
I said you know my complaint is not to
you not directed at you but can you
please ask your journalists to raise
this question that when the public
health infrastructure is barely existent
how on Earth do these people shamelessly
fly all the way to the U.S for an eye
exam and why are the journalists asking
these questions and his answer was
ma'am you know their hands are tied
and that is my request to you first of
all thank you for choosing independent
journalism I think it is very very
important to keep democracy alive and if
you can address this issue
um in you know when you go back and you
know just bring some awareness around
this that
um yeah no thank you and I'll I'll
follow this up but it's kind of similar
to you know in India we're having this
whole debate around language uh I don't
know how many of you have been following
it and a recent sort of parliamentary
panel recommended that and parts of it
as support and emphasis on uh Regional
languages on on the fact that people uh
should should know Hindi and also if
you're in Tamil Nadu Tamil and you know
just whatever your own language is but
the operative part of it is this attempt
to remove the Primacy of English because
it's a colonial language and I
I just think that if we were to just
pull out you know how many people how
many of our political class send their
children to English medium schools I
think the the hypocrisy of that would be
evident to see so I think it's similar I
think those who can get uh treatment
outside of India in politics in society
even in media would and I think I mean
there's definitely a story if it's being
done on taxpayers money but otherwise
it's a story of double speak right where
you encourage the poor to say You must
get treated at at home but you fly
abroad yourself but again you know you
follow the news but I'm telling you the
real crisis is one people don't follow
the news to when they follow the news
they only follow the news that they
already agree with so they never think
that there's a reality outside of the
news they follow and they're so shocked
and so judgmental when they see that
news but that's your fellow citizens who
think differently and I think the real
crisis is for me is that if you can't
create of consensus on certain basic
Universal values in public policy in
public health policy in you know a
bureaucrat is meant to execute like the
migrant workers it shouldn't matter
whether you vote BJP Congress trynamol
TRS it shouldn't matter it cannot matter
at this time and that the faith that
that that that ideological battles today
obstruct
Partnerships in policy making is
something that deeply concerns me
because honestly people who work in this
space have to work with all governments
they can't afford to bring their
political meanings to being public
policy or public health experts a Doctor
Who heads all India Medical Institute is
not going to say I vote this way so I
will now not
you you know what I mean so when we talk
about news consumption I mean I will
follow up what you've told me but I I
will briefly also say that please do
engage with news outside of the news
that you already agree with
and it's important
honestly it's important
yeah it is
I think there's a couple of questions
here
yeah yeah go ahead
foreign
like education during pandemic and how
education was one of the last things
that would open up in India when U.S and
UK probably did it like six or seven
months before so as you were traveling
particularly in 2021 did you see did you
see people on the ground talking about
it did you see any concerns about
educational institutes being closed and
particularly with uh the birth of uh
mobile phones or laptops so that they
can attend virtual classes uh what did
you see on the ground about that oh I
saw um in particular lower income groups
people desperate for schools to reopen
desperate like there was a kind of
desperation and the one thing that
actually there was a kind of
um class Eunice the non-verse please
open schools uh obviously for the poor
as I said with the child marriages and
so on the costs were different but I
think you now have enough data on the
fact that children's cognitive skills
social skills emotional skills learning
skills all of them have been really
really sort of egregiously hit uh in the
last two years the other thing I saw was
porno families were really dipping into
savings to pay the fees of private
schools and those fees didn't
automatically stop so what was really
happening was this big crisis where
incomes had halted but the school fee
still had to be paid otherwise you would
lose your spot in the school
and a month among the more it just came
to me the one of the most tragic stories
I reported it was a young girl who was
the daughter of an auto rickshaw driver
from Hyderabad and the and he had put
together everything he had sold the only
piece of land he had two daughters and
uh he couldn't afford to educate them
both so he had to take this decision
that I will invest my savings in the one
who seems to show more scholarly promise
so he managed to get her into lady
shiram College which is a premier
College in Delhi and when it was
announced that uh classes had to go
online she was so distracted because she
didn't have a lab at all and and she
took her whole life
and and so you know I think we
underestimate what education means
especially to those I mean I I know that
there were kids who had to be pulled out
of school because their parents had lost
their job and the suddenly couldn't
afford uh you know to pay the fees fees
was a major issue so this is again an
example of a disconnect this is what
people cared about but this was not on
the media
it was just not on the media and and
everywhere people would be like can you
please like we're just desperate
for women who wanted to go back to work
to those hours in the day where your
children went to school
um was also about your space to do
something or for poorer families the
absence of a midday mail scheme a hot
one cooked meal so we have to join the
dots between all of these things so I
picked up a lot of this but it was
unmovable you could not move policy
across government you could not and by
the way in many cases parents of
privileged classes some were very in
favor of opening some were very opposed
to it and the absence of their consensus
mean no schools
okay we have an online question and this
may be our last question because we're
short on time
um so the question is can you comment on
the similarities and differences between
covering covet and covering more so
that's a great question and I actually
if I had to bookend my life not that I
plan to retire but if I had to book in
my life uh in journalism it would be
from kargil to covet
um both it were the toughest stories
I've ever reported are both transformed
me personally
um
I I when I went to cover War I had to
really fight as a woman to be allowed to
the warfront there were no mobile phones
at that time there was no um broadcast
living
capacity to to to to broadcast live we
would still film on tape we would walk
kilometers in the mountains to find
Chopper pilots who could take take our
tapes back it was obviously life and
death very risky
um and yet again my attempt there was to
humanize and understand the psychology
of the Indian soldier who was really 24
25 years old and I wanted to understand
what a young man they were all men then
infantry continues to be all men even
today what a young man thinks when he's
walking into
possible death you know how do how do
how does courage and vulnerability
coexist so it was kind of very
transforming for me personally and among
the toughest scariest riskier stories I
had ever done till it came to covet uh
where two there was so much unknown and
you know in in Cargill at least you knew
that there were Pakistani Intruders
sitting on the Indian mountain peaks and
they were going to bomb you and you had
to hide when the bomb came and you had
to take cover and I didn't always know
what to do I was very young uh but I
learned certain things you know I
learned I had a female producer with me
when we were traveling across India for
covet and I don't notice because I've
done this for so long that there are no
bathrooms for women along the way like
I'm I'm just picking up something small
where we're talking about the gendered
experience the generous piece of
reporting so men can take a leak
wherever they want but there's nothing
and she was just modified and I had
because I had been trained in this you
know I had done this in Cargill there
were no clothes there were no bathrooms
there was no food so in a way I had been
prepared for this moment
possibly because I had reported War but
this was longer than water
this was just longer and it reminds me
actually I'll end with that story it
reminds me of a nurse that I met in a
hospital in Bombay and
you know on 26 11 which was India's 9 11
when terrorists came into Bombay the
city of Bombay and there was a three-day
Siege two of them entered this Hospital
in Bombay and this nurse had been on
neonatal Duty so she was on duty in a
ward where there were all these new
mothers and their babies and when these
terrorists came in with their assault
rifles she switched off all the lights
and she had the presence of mind to take
away all the all the all the phones and
and and and and and and turn them off
and somehow managed to save lives and
then she was on covet Duty and I
remember meeting her and I said you know
which is tougher and she said look
they're apples and oranges but this is
so long I think it'll never end at least
that night ended right and I think for
me
both are the most meaningful work that
I've done both are the scariest work
I've done both have transformed me
personally at different stages in my
life but both teach you the same lesson
what is the job of a journalist the job
of a journalist is to go to a place that
your audience cannot access to ask the
questions that your audience wants to
know but may have nobody asking but also
to ask the questions that nobody else is
asking and you have to do all three and
be that bridge and therefore the lesson
from both stories is the same that is my
role as a report
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Barka that was an amazing
honor a bit and I'd invite everyone to
come outside and join us to talk to
barca in a more informal setting now
thank you everyone for coming and thank
you to everyone online thank you
[Music]